i chose jezebel for our sources perfect
on purpose
jezebel reports nicki minaj just tried
to dox two reporters it seems like she
isn't very happy about what's going on
there's a question mark there i don't
know how to read it with the upward
inflection uh jezebel is a bad website
they're uh not they're they're not a
good website but i thought it'd be
interesting to pull up jezebel because
here's what i find fascinating
jezebel's supposed to be like feminist
feminists right
supposedly feminist websites that's the
right thing why are they defending the
daily mail
isn't that in that weird so anyway
they prattle on for quite a bit and then
somewhere near the bottom they go on to
mention
she hopped on instagram and posted
screenshots to her story that allegedly
show a conversation between a reporter
in trinidad attempting to contact some
of her family members one assumes this
reporter must be doing so in order to
verify the claims of swollen balls but
we will likely never know the truth
because minaj also used her story to
attempt to dox the reporters by posting
a picture of a business card a name and
a phone number and that it was a mail
online business card
like it's a murdock company i'm
jezebel's feminist and they're all a
sudden difference these people have they
claim like these these are bad outlets
and now all of a sudden they're
journalists okay sure whatever
but anyway for those that promote the
story
i'll give you the quick version nicki
minaj tweeted that her cousin
her cousin's friend
got the vaccine became impotent his
balls swole up and then his fiancee left
him which is like an absolutely insane
and ridiculous story i i personally like
based on everything i don't think that
anything with the vaccine
but but nicki minaj was just telling a
story she heard so okay journalists got
all angry and they started making fun of
her she then said two things she didn't
want to travel because of her baby she
then said the met gala wanted people to
get vaccinated and if she was going to
get vaccinated wouldn't be for the met
gala
then the narrative became nicki minaj
refuses to attend met gala due to
vaccine mandates and a fear of swollen
balls which wouldn't
it's over the top and then she's like yo
you're lying i didn't say that
and the media what they do is they they
take what she said and twist it to the
legal extent they can without getting
sued but nicki minaj got 180 million
followers so she's she's going she's
going nuclear on this let me let me show
you what she posted
and uh
so well let's get rid of that
she says
she posts one thread i'm not gonna
read necessarily the the conversation
it's just like a journalist like their
names and stuff she says threatening my
family and trinidad won't bode well for
you
in trinidad harassing my family i didn't
want to give details but now i will and
this is a guy named james fielding we
blocked out his information they're
forcing my family to have to hide out
this is what speaking up looks like
millions of poor people are treated this
way by people you think are the good
guys this is unconscionable that one
well that was surprising to me because
she's now pointing out like these people
are bad guys they're claiming to be the
good guys of the bad guys she said
charlene ramper said [ __ ] your days are
effing numbered you dirty hoe
spicy
nicky
you know what i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna cheer for like that level of
you know behemoths yeah but i will i
will say
fighting back that i respect like i was
gonna say like i'm against doxing people
but the key word there is people
not internet whole monitors that's jobs
to do what these people are doing and i
don't know it's these people like see
all see themselves as gods to some
extent and i do think it's time they
sort of get some pushback and and who
better than someone with a 100 million
uh rapid followers to join in that's
exactly it it's like final you know
there's a bunch of little guys out there
who get pushed around and lied about
there was that cnn story we were
actually talking about before the show
cnn's like we're gonna dox this guy if
he posts a meme one more time and it's
like these these are people are insane
they target the little guy and now
they've gone after nicki minaj who is
the opposite of the little guy she's a
juggernaut yeah
maybe like celebrities we all don't
really like are kind of the are our way
forward that's like the secret to defeat
these people i don't know well it's you
see all the conservatives are like
cheering her on like yeah she's one of
us now and it's like no she agrees she
agrees on one issue like we don't have
to accept them fully but you know it is
nice when we can align here and there
she is one of us because whatever this
side is we're talking about the other
day the cult and the not cult that is
true i don't agree with conservatives on
a lot of things and like i i always like
to mention that i went on glenn beck's
show we're sitting in this big movie
studio basically because glenn beck's
the blaze offices are ridiculously
massive
and we have like this microphone hanging
down or whatever and we're arguing pro
choice versus pro-life with smiles on
our faces and a handshake and like wow
that was a really great conversation and
we're like yeah i remember i have i
thought the other day too or i'm like i
think with me like if i had to you know
start a new country it's more the people
and the policies like i would rather
have
our legislature but where we can
actually talk to each other and actually
converse and and instead of just you
know defaming each other and you know do
what the left does where they reinvent
the meaning of words like i would rather
have a more sane populist with a
diversity of opinion than an only
right-wing country because i mean i
don't know what kind of right-wing would
be even and what are there what are
there people i don't like so that see
what i think is important
i would say that's never going to happen
there are some instances where i'll see
the right do something that i consider
to be disingenuous or just like
exaggerated or hyperbolic you know there
was one where recently happened joe
biden was like wearing sunglasses and
eating ice cream running around
and he said something like he was asking
about trump and he goes ah trump i don't
said
robert e lee
wouldn't afghanistan i don't want to
talk about it or whatever
and they were like look he's stuttering
and mumbling and he can't speak and i'm
like no that time it just sounds like he
was sounded like he was uninterested
and was being dismissive yeah you don't
need to pretend that joe biden can't
speak we can all hear him say tune in on
a pressure
that's what it was but it's uh with with
the quote unquote right or the not cult
it's it's a mix it's independent voters
you've got like look you've got people
like jimmy dore right you know jimmy
dore's a socialist as far as i know i'm
i'm not saying to be
derogatory like i think he actually
identifies as a socialist and i think
jimmy's fantastic
and he points out a lot of the same
manipulations and lies in the media yeah
so
jimmy dore sitting down with a
conservative they're probably going to
be arguing like crazy but then they're
going to completely agree on the
establishment the feds the war the
manipulation so when nicki minaj comes
out and she's like the media lies
and i'm not going to stand for it's like
yes
this is basically what we're talking
about the people who can who who are
discerning they look at the media and
they question the narratives and the
people who aren't who believe whatever
they're told so you someone so nicki
minaj tweets this thing like they're
lying about me michael malus tweeted at
her the corporate press of the enemy of
the people and then someone responded
nicki minaj's on the side of the far
right
here we go but that's that's the cult i
mean that's the weird thing about the
left too and making every common sense
position far right is like you're going
to actually normalize the far right
which is not necessarily something you
want to do either right but
it's not even far right michael it's not
at all right i was thinking about how
it's not a volleyball game where it's
like half of us and half of us it's more
like mold toxicity has entered the
system wait so it's not like an
aberration like it's there and we can
locate it it hits the system and then it
disperses throughout so we've got these
bits of like toxicity in the system but
it's a small percentage of the system
although it's affecting it yeah and then
every the rest of the system's just
functioning and now we're all kind of
trying to work together i got a crazy
idea you know get the right to get on
board with universal health care and
actually it's not even my joke it's the
babylon b trump trump comes out and
supports a support of impeachment
forcing democrats to oppose that
yeah so i'm not even going to claim the
joke it's a recycled joke but yeah if
the right came out and they were like we
support the green new deal and aoc the
aoc is far right
because you can't convert people on the
right yeah politics
someone did that with cnn where i think
they were arguing for like paid
maternity leave and then ivanka trump
proposed not that policy but a tax
credit for for mothers and then cnn
wrote an article about why it was why
that was actually a horrible policy
well it's the world we live in yeah the
cult that's why i call it the cult
because like we can i can sit down and
have a conversation about border policy
with libertarians and you have
libertarians who are prone for and
against borders and the people the
libertarians who are like open borders
are the only true libertarian position
and the other person is like no no there
should be borders otherwise you have a
country and it's like
those conversations can happen yeah
we've been trying to get people to come
on with alex jones we want a leftist to
come on they won't do it
because they're scared of him not
because you know you know what the funny
thing is they're scared because he's
gonna be right because when joe rogan
had him on and joe rogan kept fact
checking him and then he joe would be
like alex that's not true and alex's
back look it up i'm telling you and then
jamie pull it up and then oh yeah i
found it it's true it's cnn reporting
2016 some weird thing when he was here
alex told me that we eat cloned beef
he's like all the beef you're eating
it's all clones and i'm like no it isn't
that's ridiculous and he's like look
google it typed it in and
dozens of articles all of the meat you
get is from cloned cows and i was like
oh so what happens is we have these
leftists some of them are like yeah i'll
do the show and then later go no no i'm
not going to do it yeah because what are
they going to do when they sit down
across from alex jones and he says
something populist like we can't have
these elites stealing money from the
working class and they're going to be
like i agree with you alex jones and
then that's gonna get clipped yeah and
put everywhere they're scared they're
scared because
now i certainly think alice has been
crazy and wrong about a lot of things
well he said nut but i like the guy but
but when he talks about
nobody wants to be in the room with the
guy these leftists don't where they get
a sound bite whether in agreement with
him over basic issues when he's talking
about 5g cell towers and mutant animal
hybrids and weird stuff like it's
the left can't agree with the right on a
single issue
we can agree with a single issue with
nicki minaj and go yeah we'll align with
you there but like they'll find someone
they agree with on everything or or even
like they're canceling within their own
like like they'll find something growth
and everything and be like oh he said a
homophobic term and xbox live in 2003
and we gotta you know oh what was that
the jeopardy guy yes posted nine i think
it was nine years ago
and then it's so weird too because you
see you can see it play out in twitter
the whole process and all the other
journalists like wow great job uh
transcribing this nine-year-old podcast
you know i knew about like great work
guys
yeah he said boobs or something it was
something it was something so
i mean i already forgot what it was
which would give you
dude i i say it all the time but like i
don't understand how people would choose
to live that way like nicki minaj is
willing to put her career on the line
because she's like screw you i'm not
going to do what you say how is it nicki
minaj's more more punk rock than rage
against the machine
that's the thing with the left
they always have an issue no matter how
obscure like i'll be friends with them
on facebook from college and they're
like oh this native tribe in the middle
of this place you've never heard of
needs our help and i'm like how do you
guys keep track of all this
i'm not saying it's bad to care i'm just
saying i don't get how you guys it must
be exhausting i'm i'm looking forward to
like nikki doing new songs yeah because
she might incorporate oh it's all it's
all gonna be red pills yeah and and
she's it's it's like
you think back to that line from rage
against the machine
i'm sorry rage on behalf of the machine
where they said f you i won't do what
you tell me and now they're
they're lying we should rewrite that
song f you you better do what they tell
you and they're not they were never
really anti-establishment like if you uh
well they actually did a tour i think
was sponsored by pepsi once but um you
might want to check that but um on
tamro's guitar the the um the black one
i don't know what it's called i'm not
into music but um it referenced the
shining path which is a peruvian
communist group that killed 60 000
people yeah
so so that's the kind of people he's
probably supporting i mean it doesn't
really seem uh all that
anti-establishment or you're reveling
against but when the establishment in
the u.s opposes communism throughout the
establishment yes so that so that's the
funny thing right you've got some people
who are who are this this is what i've
what i've found
i was having a conversation with this
hacker guy
relatively prominent prominent during
the anonymous era occupy wall street
and i was like we were arguing and i was
like dude you guys changed like we
didn't change we still believe in free
speech we still believe in all these
things and then he just was like yeah i
know we used you
like we were anti-establishment because
we want to subvert you know the the
authority and take over and install our
communist you know utopia
and you were willing to help us do it so
we tolerated it now that we have
institutional authority we don't believe
in freedom and we never did it was just
a means to an end yeah
that's that's the thing in politics in
general like people are only really
principled so long as you know it gets
them into power um i think only the
right really stays principal but it's
almost to their detriment at certain
times like you'll see them be weak on
vaccine mandates for instance and say
well we can't really tell businesses
what to do or they'll go ahead no no no
i should uh i don't want to drop drop i
didn't want to interrupt no i was going
to i wanted to ask though um because you
might know this dude has lauren bobert
proposed repealing the nfa
uh i mean i assume not um but i don't
know the uh i actually follow her that
much so
someone may have let me look it up yeah
i'm not entirely sure but that's a
national firearms act it bans tons of
weapons it makes it nearly impossible to
get specific specific guns that so i i i
i think shouldn't even make sense to be
banned but there's a ridiculous amount
of guns that are banned people don't
understand that not only is there a
ridiculous amount of guns that are
banned but there's also a ridiculous
amount of guns that can't even be made
because of the nfa and other atf
regulations and rules
so so it looks like senator cramer the
u.s senator for north dakota introduced
a bill to abolish the nfa senator kramer
and colleagues introduced bill to
improve firearm owner's access oh one
was just uh this is from june 2021 but
this is okay that's great so i don't
know is is that guy he's he's in right
now and he's doing that yeah
i wasn't i wasn't doing that to drag
lauren pogba by anybody anyway it's just
because she is very very much a two-way
candidate and i'm wondering like are the
republicans coming out and being like
you know we demand right
seemingly not no
no yeah it's the thing republicans will
get power and then they'll go well if
you know we use the government to
enforce our principles the left will do
it when they take power and it's like
well they already are i mean
it's almost like a meme that schools are
left wing it's like are you guys letting
me get that way but that's that's the
point yeah i'm not asking for lo and be
lauren bobert or any or martial taylor
green i need rand paul to demand the
government give us stuff i'm saying
repeal the law and let people decide on
their own
but you know the issue is
you got a game of tug of war with the
left pulling with all their might and
the right's just standing still yeah
they do tweet a lot though so you've got
the fear that's true of not getting
voted back in if they anger too many
people if they get too loud so they're
kind of like they don't want to make a
noise like i didn't even know who that
guy was you just mentioned kevin cameron
yeah but there's a lot of a lot of
members of congress you don't know but
come on look at aoc
she stomps around yeah yeah i think her
heart is like she's not one of those i
think it's like d plus 25 like basically
you could run a dead democrat against a
republican in her district and a dead
person would win unfortunately you could
run a sawhorse yeah i mean it's
literally possible it's a you know kim
klasik level district so it's nothing i
mean no that's that's the crazy thing
too and this is not an exaggeration or a
joke if you put sawhorse
saw space horse d
and you know john smith r
the saw horse would win
because people will just see the d and
then check it off regardless there's
some
town i don't know if i guys always saw
the headline but where i think a cat won
the mayoral election which maybe maybe
that was just a joke on the people's
part there's there's a lot of there's a
lot of small towns with only a couple
hundred people they'll vote for the dog
yeah because they're like we don't need
a mayor what's the point yeah yeah but i
actually think i wonder if if this can
be you know pulled off if you can
in
i wonder what would happen if you just
went to a district
got someone who's a republican on the
ballot as a democrat i've had that
thought like you run and you you
you lead with your issues that are
left-leaning and just you know kind of
stay quiet on the other ones but you
don't need it doesn't even matter if you
can get if if there's like some obscure
district and you run and it's d plus 28
and you run as a democrat and you win
the primary
see the issue i suppose is running the
primary is very activisty because that's
where all the hardcore
activists are
but what's to stop a republican from
protect from doing you know pulling an
aoc and being like i'm far left and then
getting in and then go right to the i
know this is establishment this is just
a sheriff election but i think that's
what i was like david clarke the black
sheriff used to be on fox news a lot um
very conservative but he is a registered
democrat i think it's sort of the same
thing he's in an area where you kind of
have to be even though what he's saying
is not that way um i think that's the
sim the answer answer to the problem
yeah and so so a republican runs as a
democrat and democrat district and then
votes reports yeah i think no one pays
attention to those local politics right
like i i i mean i know who my
representative is i don't know who any
of the other ones are and i don't think
i doubt half people in my town and my
town even know who theirs is so yeah i
think it would be possible
you know well that's the thing about uh
aoc's district she won the primary with
what was it like 11 000 votes
wow so imagine if right a republican ran
as a democrat
and told all of the republicans because
there's i think how many are there two
200 000
or it's like 120 000 republicans in
aoc's district i think is there yeah
interesting it's like 20 20
so it's actually a little bit more like
150.
imagine if you got 20 000 activist
republicans to vote in the democratic
primary for the conservative democrat
although was the eleven thousand was
that her
or her like didn't she have like a
runoff with the incumbent or something
joe crowley i think was aoc yeah like it
wasn't a runoff she won the primary oh
that's what was it so that's what it was
11 000 to the primary and then and then
and then she wins that was it and now i
don't know why it must be misremembering
something weird i don't know no it might
have been i think it might have been 17
000. oh he got 14. but either either way
the point is it was like in a district
of 750 000 that's all you needed to win
yeah okay republicans run as it run as a
centrist democrat just vote and get all
the republicans to vote for you and then
once you're in be like oh i'm joining
the republican party and then you've got
new york's 14 as a republican district
in new york
like uh like what was what was jeff
andrew oh yeah you saw that guy he was
in new jersey
he was a moderate democrat he won in 20
uh yeah he's flipped right yeah he
flipped because of the impeachment he
was like they're nuts yeah and uh did he
won again didn't he i think so i think i
think he's from i think he's south
jersey which is the more conservative
half of the
massive trump i'm thinking like we're
thinking like strip the d and the r off
the tickets try that and then just but
then just vote and you have to know who
you're voting for but then it'd be
whoever the coolest name you get people
would change their names like lightning
smash and then you were heading towards
camacho and indiana
maybe the age of the popularity contest
should be i'd make my my name like
election losers people would vote for me
as a joke nobody
yeah yeah oh yeah nobody nobody wins and
i gotta say i think it's still better
the slashing the d's in the arctic
we would be better off if in deep red
and deep blue districts a random person
won
i don't i really don't like the people
dropped for the d or the r that always
bothers me that's that's all they do
there was a story of the uh trans
anarchist satanist in new hampshire i
think it was new hampshire right i don't
know that that
ran as a republican
and won
it was a primary though that's awesome
and it was because republicans are just
like yup yup republican republican and
then when the republicans these voters
found out they were like what i'm
outraged and the the trans anarchist
satanist said to them
you voted for me are they still a
republican do we know i don't know i
don't know but um i i thought that was
brilliant absolutely brilliant
send a message to these people who walk
in and go oh mitch mcconnell he's a
republican lindsay graham no yeah i know
the the the establishment republicans
are speed bumps for democrats and it's
intentional as far as as far as i'm
concerned what do you uh what do you
guys think about having more parties
because i i've floated in both ways
where i'm like on one hand like it
allows people to be more honest because
like optionally like within the
republican party there's probably three
or four different factions um but on the
other hand it could risk making the
country more divided in that you know
instead of one the blue team versus the
red team if you've got eight teams that
are it would be a good thing you think
but it's not possible in first pass the
post voting systems well that's that we
would it would need to be like europe
where you vote for the party and then
whatever percent they get you know
like the parliamentary system yeah yeah
where basically it's like if seventy
percent of the vote is for republicans
and republicans get 70 on the scenes i'm
a little ignorant on how they fill this
seat i don't know if the party picks
them or what goes on i think i think the
party i assume that's right but i'm not
sure yet uh
if we had
10 libertarian seats
in in the house it would force the
democrats and republicans to compromise
yeah i want like a libertarian party a
nationalist party like a i don't think
like a tea party day party and the left
can have their you know crazy different
factions like a green party or something
maybe in a range
or something like that yeah right
because look at it this way there's uh
bernie sanders
is notorious for compromising and
working with republicans and that's why
they called kamala harris the most
liberal member of the of of congress
yeah so not true it was just based on
one year's voting i think that
particularly it was it was based on
cooperation bernie sanders was willing
to cooperate and sponsor republicans in
exchange for their support on his bills
right and his bills were substantially
more progressive but he knew where his
paths were and kamala harris was just
not talking republicans at all that
doesn't make her fur further left than
bernie but that's how they they they
weighed it yeah i think another thing
too is like bernie there are certain
policies there's literally no point in
proposing because it's they're not gonna
go anywhere um so obviously he has
radical beliefs but they don't show up
in the record because you know it's just
never going to pass thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you